[Music]
you're looking at a shot of the white
house and with good reason we welcome
you back to cbs morning because today
marks one year since president joe biden
and vice president kamala harris took
office at a news conference yesterday
the president announced harris will be
on the ticket with him in 2024 if he
decides to run again now that's the
first time that we've heard that they
could run together for reelection
harris's vice presidency has been
historic as you know because she's the
first woman and the first person of
color to serve in this position she
joined us earlier this morning to
discuss the highs and lows of the last
year
and now vice president harris joins us
good morning to you madam vice president
it's good to see you
good morning gail good to be with you
you know i know it was a very long night
in the senate last night as expected the
voting rights legislation did not pass
last night in in part because of two of
your own party members but the president
says he can take action to protect the
voting rights what specifically are you
going to do
well thank you gail first of all it's
really important for everyone to
understand what's at stake
around our country there have been
purposeful direct attempts to make it
more difficult for people to vote access
to the ballot and so that's the issue
when we talk about voting rights attacks
on our democracy if you boil it down to
it one of the specific issues is that
folks are making it people in elected
offices in states are making it more
difficult for their citizens to vote so
for example they are making it more
difficult for people to vote by mail
well think about folks who have
disabilities
parents who have you know
obligations every day or work two or
three shifts voting by mail is the best
way they can vote they're passing laws
eliminating or reducing the number of
drop boxes again if you're a single
parent a mom or a dad you got those
three kids in the back seat and and you
want to vote and it's much easier for
you to fill out your ballot at home and
drop it drive by drop it in the drop box
than to have those kids stand with you
in line um what do we need to do
so what are you going to do i mean you
all have laid out your case very very
nicely about what's at stake and now
we're here and it didn't pass so what
will you do
well what we will do is we will keep
fighting to get the legislation passed
because that is critical so we are not
giving up on that and then it is a
matter of continuing to do the work of
executive orders doing the work through
the department of justice which has been
litigating these cases in the various
states because we believe that they are
a violation of the spirit of the
constitution of the united states it is
going to be about continuing to elevate
this conversation because gail frankly
you'd be surprised how many people in
the the burden of everyday life are
unaware of what's happening in these
states but when they become aware of
laws that make it illegal to give people
food and water if they're standing in
line they're outraged we heard the
president say that he intends to get out
of the bubble of the white house and go
and take the message directly to the
people but at this point i know it's
only one year it's your one year
anniversary today you've got three years
to go but the polling is not good so far
the cbs polling out today shows only 44
percent of americans approve of your job
in particular that you all have failed
to pass the bill back better voting
rights and police reform what's your new
strategy to get this done and i know
you've got three years to go what's the
new strategy so
well let's just say to your the point i
think the spirit of your question
polls go up and down but we have to
remain consistent in fighting for the
american people and their needs and so
that is the strategy about staying
focused i'm not going to give up on the
issue of affordable child care i know do
that without any parents madam vice
president can you do that without
congress you know i i will tell you and
you'll appreciate this gail last week i
was in atlanta and i had a visit with
ambassador andy young
who was who was probably one of the last
living members of those leaders who
marched with and advised dr king
and he said to me you know we had ups
and downs in the fight for civil rights
and for progress in this country but you
can't give up and you can't give up on
the spirit of the american people to
want things to be better
and that's how i feel i take that
seriously so yes we're not going to give
up on affordable child care we're not
going to give up on some of these issues
that really get to the heart of what
people need and they want they want
solutions they want things to be fixed
they want to enjoy their families and
not have to worry about some of these
issues
let's turn to ukraine and russia because
i'm wondering if you all are having a
cleanup in aisle three in the state
department today where the president
raised a couple of eyebrows when he
seemed to make the distinction between a
minor incursion and an all-out invasion
and so
the people in ukraine today we
understand are very upset with that
because they believe that the president
has given biden has given rather uh
president putin the green light what do
you say to that because it does seem to
be very confusing
so
the president let me just first tell you
i start every morning reading the
presidential daily briefing
which contains classified information
about threats to our national security
and hot spots around the world i am
often in meetings in the situation room
where the president and i and members of
our leadership of our military our
intelligence community convene on these
issues the president of the united
states joe biden has been very clear on
the subject of ukraine which is that if
russia takes aggressive action there
will be severe and swift
consequences that there will be he
didn't seem to say that yesterday though
at the news conference that's why
there's some that's why i think
clarification is needed
well we are very clear and we've been
very clear
with putin
that
any aggressive action taken by russia
will meet a cost a severe cost let's
let's talk about covet because you all
ran on we are going to get covet under
control we are going to get this
lit
and as we sit here today as you know
we're going into year three we are still
talking about cobin you all admitted
listen we've made some mistakes we're
going to do better we're going to be
better the schools can the kids go to
schools in new mexico the national guard
is bringing is being asked to be
substitute teachers all because of covid
so it is not under control so i'm
wondering
what is your strategy here and have you
come to the point have you come to the
point that we have all got to figure out
how to live with coping
so
i'm going to try to unpack the various i
know there's a lot
but they're important so let's start
with our children okay
which should always be where we start
frankly if you look at where we were
last year where we were certainly at the
beginning of this pandemic we know that
compared comparing then to now we've
seen great progress where over 95
percent of our schools are open we now
have vaccines for our children who are
over the age of five so we have seen
great progress we as an administration
put 310 billion dollars into the schools
of america to help upgrade ventilation
systems and make sure that they have the
resources they need to keep both our
children and their teachers safe in the
school people will say
madam vice president it's not enough and
have you reached the point that you have
to say we've got to figure out a way to
live with this or do you still believe
we can get this under control
there is still more work to be done
we started out with very few people
getting vaccinated and we now have 210
million americans who have been
vaccinated we need everyone to take
seriously and take advantage of the
tools that are available to them the you
know what i i will tell you gail that
one of the things that inspires me
about this moment in the midst of
everything is the incredible power of
the american people to take advantage of
the tools that are available to them and
say that they're not going to let things
happen to them
they're going to actually do what they
have in their power and that includes
getting vaccinated it includes wearing
masks
there's still more work we must do
absolutely absolutely absolutely
yeah the white house admits they're just
as frustrated as we all are with coped
but the bottom line is what you are what
are you going to do what are you going
to do yeah and the same is true when it
comes to international affairs and the
situation in ukraine i don't think
americans have an appetite for troops on
the ground there and so it's got to be
sanctions and it doesn't seem like putin
cares about sanctions on the other hand
people say look this is only one year
it's in the middle of a pandemic there's
three years to go there's still work to
be done and they want to do the work i
know but there's that midterm vote